casque sur la tête le directeur de
l'eeie a écoutent les explications de
l'un des responsables de la centrale de
zaporijia raphaël grossit et très autres
membres du gendarme international du
nucléaire sont arrivés à la mi journée
sur le site occupé par les troupes
russes depuis mars dernier une première
journée d'inspection et un premier
constat positif
nous avons pu en quelques heures
rassemblé beaucoup beaucoup
d'informations
nous allons donc poursuivre nos analyses
nous avons accompli quelque chose de
très important aujourd'hui est le plus
important c'est que la iaa reste ici
fait savoir au monde que là il reste à
zaporijia
la volonté de l'agencé internationale à
l'énergie atomique de rester sur place
sur le long terme semblent avoir été
entendus par la partie russe même si une
partie seulement de la délégation est
pour l'instant resté sur place raphaël
grossi lui est reparti du côté ukrainien
de la ligne de front qui l'avait passé
dans le sens contraire dans la matinée
après avoir fait le point avec le
ministre ukrainien de l'énergie il donne
quelques détails aux journalistes
présents
malgré le fait que je ne suis resté que
quatre ou cinq heures sur place j'ai vu
beaucoup de choses j'ai mon équipe sur
place j'ai pu faire le tour de tout le
site je suis rentré dans les différentes
unités
l'inquiétude demeure sur la possibilité
de fuites radioactives
voire d'accidents nucléaires d'autant
que le directeur de l'eeie a confirme
que l'intégrité physique de la centrale
a été violée et témoigne de la poursuite
des échanges de tirs d'artillerie de
part et d'autre du fleuve dniepr à l'est
duquel se trouve la centrale ukrainienne
et russes continuent de se renvoyer la
responsabilité des bombardements moscou
a même affirmé que des commando de
saboteurs ukrainien avait tenté de se
rendre sur le site de la centrale
l'opérateur nucléaire ukrainien a par
ailleurs annoncé que l'un des réacteurs
du site avait été stoppé à cause des
combats